Texas son
many cities and states boast of having the
best barbecue you've heard the claims from
Kansas City Memphis and North Carolina and
of course add Texas to that list where it
seems like there's a joint on every corner but
few can claim the rich Heritage of davila's
barbecue we asked our Texas correspondent
cbs's Janet shamlian to give it a try
41. I got you I got you guys
in the city of Seguin there
you are davila's barbecue is destination dining
and it's Destiny for Adrian Davila this is
where I'm in my my element the most is fire meat
he's a third generation Pit Master
decades after his grandfather started
the restaurant in an old schoolhouse
cooking in front the family living in
bed whenever you're trying to live up
to a such a legend as my grandfather was in the
community as far as the barbecue space like he
was his Grandmaster because he didn't leave
the pits every stick of wood every piece of
meat every sausage that was hung it's him his
decision only nobody else touched the pits so
that barbecue always came out with his stamp on
it and you felt that responsibility absolutely
my hairs are standing up right now you still do
I still do Raul Davila was a butcher by trade
indelible memories for Adrian I remember him
taking something that the time was so Primal
as a big cut of me and breaking it down and making
something beautiful with it and when it came out
under the table and people enjoyed it that was
astonishing to me Adrian's dad Edward took over
in the mid 90s making his own mark thank you sir
46 son to work in the family the j-46 yeah okay
envisioning something better even though it's
all Adrian wanted but when again I was able
to see what it created and how you created
memories with food birthdays celebrations
anniversaries weddings you create memories and
I just that that hooked me all right guys so
did his family's culinary history this is your
place all right yes this is the ranch inspired
by Vaquero's Mexican cattle herders Davila took
us to his Ranch this is what we call a barbacoa
for a look at how they slow cooked meat like this
lamb in an underground pit let's see the magic
happened you know how they have like the pool oh
my goodness a tradition he's keeping alive today
look at that is that ready to eat when it's
falling apart like that there's nothing but
you see the seeds of the Tomato the onion and
the jalapeno the carols would celebrate like
this Davila says an outdoor Feast at a colorful
table takes a lot of love and passion to create
all this and that's what makes it so satisfying oh
okay influenced by the past but with an eye to the
Future Adrian now runs Davos that means new items
like the barbecue grilled cheese sandwich chopped
brisket sauteed onions just a little butter on
there huh Texas toast and lots of cheese get
every little bit in there you have to try this
okay now one of the best selling on the menu
that's unbelievable can we sell more of these per
day then we do our regular barbecue sandwiches
really imagine that as if we needed more Davila
prepared for us just about everything he sells
their Signature Sausage still hand tied every day
this is exactly the way my grandfather made it not
changing the recipe ribs are a barbecue staple
and almost always pork but here they're lamb
go ahead and have a short bite okay and then the
vinegar of the pickle is what you got to follow
up with chains are right into the sauce dessert
is big red cake let's have a big red cake do you
do this to go yeah yes one of our biggest sellers
right there really oh yeah made with soda of the
same name a tribute to his grandparents so it's
big red oh my goodness my siblings and I would
go to Grandma and Grandpa's house it was that
big red cake in the fridge it's our favorite
thing for Adrian Davila it's always been about
family from his wife Sarah his inspiration and
teammate to the men who held title davila's
Pit Master before him I was watching your dad
watch you and you couldn't see it but I saw
the pride in his eyes he's so proud of you
that's what we all want right we're born with
this inherent trait to satisfy our parents it's
human everybody wants it satisfy their parents
right everybody wants to make their parents proud
foreign the steward of a proud
family Legacy davolos one of a kind
for CBS Saturday morning I'm Janet shamlin in
Seguin Texas I love the fact that he wants to
make his Papa and Mama Proud he's done more than
that yeah he certainly has and he's brought in
some food for us here as well I mean this is
this looks incredible and dig in but Janet had
a field day I not dish what did I just say
she did it right I want that grilled cheese
and look at this this is whiskey right that's
the best way pour it in here in a little sweet
tea because that's how I do it cheers you're
here Dallas right davilas yeah insanely good